Patricia is on the line in Birmingham hi
Patricia how are you I'm well how are
you better than I deserve what's up okay
so I need to excersice about something
what I ultimately want to know is what
do you project my time frame for me to
pay off my debt so what I have going is
how I'm going to round up to ninety
three thousand in debt and I bring home
4100 a month and do some figuring and
tell me what your project would be a
reasonable time to have all that
completed what kind of debt is the
ninety-three thousand okay we got I'm
gonna round up again so it's easier I
have a sixty and student loan debt
I have twenty in an auto loan and I got
about a little over thirteen thousand
credit card in any medical time and
you're single I am single with three
girls okay and so it sounds like you're
making about sixty to sixty five
thousand a year - your deductions and
you get home with about forty one
hundred a month does that sound right to
you losing about I do have a part-time
I'm 11 and thousand of that well well
I'm sorry seven hundred of that a month
is normal part-time okay the most
glaring thing I see immediately is your
car payment is really big mm-hmm out of
based on your income I mean you make
sixty thousand dollars a year you have
$20,000 car debt that's big that's
really big it's not the end of the world
but it's big okay so it's simple to do
this it you know the answer the question
is how intense and sacrificial are you
going to live of course the more intense
and sacrificial you live the faster
you're going to get out of debt because
the less you're going to spend money on
anything except the debt so we're going
to get an attack mode so if you make
sixty thousand dollars a year and we
want to pay off 93
thousand dollars if we wanted to do it
in three years we'd have to pay off
$30,000 a year
that'd be $2,500 a month and that means
you literally are going to be on beans
and rice rice and beans and you're
probably selling this car and moving
down but that probably gets you out in
about three years roughly if nothing
else changes but that's how you see how
I did that I said thirty thousand out of
your 60 mm-hmm that's a lot yeah and how
much did you tell me your house payment
or your rent is my rent with that
includes water it's ten seventy is how
much 1,070 okay that's pretty healthy -
all right um well I you know you're
going after school of course I'm sure
the better school system you that's
great I'm glad the the trick is this is
a math thing and so that your question
starts to be when are you going to be
able to how much can you cut and what
can you push it down to to be able to
free up money to throw at the debt so
it's a three or a four year process for
you if you're intense the more intense
you are the faster it's going to happen
the more intense you are the more you're
going to sell and the more you're going
to work and the more you're going to cut
your budget and the more intense you are
the more you work the more you sell the
more you cut your budget the faster you
get out because it frees up money to
throw out the debt it's a math thing
that's what it comes down to I think you
can do it Patricia but you're gonna have
to lean into it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you